i know that there are a ton of uh crypto
enthusiasts traders
investors holders in the david pakman
show
audience things have been particularly
crazy lately especially since
tesla uh it was revealed tesla had
purchased 1.5 billion dollars worth of
bitcoin and plans to start
accepting it and today we are going to
be talking about
a crypto trading platform called unimex
unimex
actually sponsored this video and unimex
is an on-chain margin trading platform
entirely contained within uni swap
which means that the shorts and the
longs are all executed
on uniswap rather than through an
off-chain
approach now many of you may know that
uniswap
is the largest decentralized crypto
exchange
in the world based on the ethereum
blockchain
so unimex is a decentralized finance
protocol
and they facilitate the margin trading
of native
uniswap tokens before unimex
there was no direct way to shorter long
these uniswap tokens despite
the hundreds of millions of dollars of
aggregated daily trading volumes that
uniswap attracts and the two billion
dollar
liquidity pooled in the protocol so
this is the problem that unimex is
trying to solve and within the platform
a central factory smart contract
deploys lending pool contracts which are
smart contracts
that permit the lending of specific
erc20 tokens so
what this allows is for margin traders
to borrow them
for leveraged trading unimex only
permits the correct creation of lending
pools for tokens that are trading
within an er 20 eth uniswap
pair and in unimex a lender creates a
lending pool automatically
by calling a function on the unimex
factory
which checks that the erc20 eth pair
is actually trading on uniswap by
querying the factory
while also ensuring that the calendar
seeds the sufficient
number of the erc20 tokens to the
lending pool now
there's a restriction as to which erc20
tokens are eligible for the creation of
a lending pool
subject to the liquidity of the uniswap
trading pair unfortunately a measure of
decentralization has to be sacrificed
here
but unimex says that it's simply
necessary
to combat how easily these low liquidity
pools
can be manipulated with on-chain oracles
so central to the function of the unimex
protocol
the effect of permitting free reign on
the integration of uniswap pairs of
lower
dubious liquidity could be catastrophic
imagine pairs from fraudulent projects
likely to have most of their liquidity
pulled by the project
itself but in the medium term unimec
says
they will liberate the process of
approving the creation of lending pools
from the governance of an administrator
by subjecting the decision
to a vote which users will be able to
contribute to
by burning or staking governance tokens
all
updates to the unimex platform are
regulated
by the governance using voting via the
umx token which is the unimex
ecosystem's native token as well and all
collateral
from borrows will be denominated in
ether
although this does sacrifice some
flexibility they see this as a necessary
measure to ensure control of the margin
trading process
as every asset valuation within the
protocol
will be denominated in ether and then
finally
lenders receive fees in the denomination
of the asset borrow so
ether borrows will yield ether fees
erc20 borrows will yield erc20 fees
and so on distributed among borrowers
proportional to their stakes
in the respective lending pools unimex
imposes a 0.8 levy
on all loans when margin traders pay the
fees the vast majority of the fees are
then dispersed to lenders
as a reward for supplying the liquidity
to the lending pools
and then a tiny percentage of the fees
go to umx token
holders and a fraction of a percentage
of the fees
go to the unimex team the liquidation
reserve
and to token buybacks and token burns
so it's a pretty interesting trading
platform one that's aiming to solve an
actual problem
trying to tap into a lot of unrealized
potential when it comes to uniswap
trading you can find the platform at
unimex
dot trade all you need to use unimex
is a web3 compatible wallet or browser
you could use
metamask or trust wallet for example and
you can learn more about unimex as a
project at unimex.network
which is where you can find the white
paper and a lot of other info on the
ecosystem
check out unimex on twitter and telegram
they have a discord server
thanks to unimex for sponsoring this
video and of course
nothing in this video is financial
advice everyone should be
investigating and doing all due
diligence on everything
that they do within the realm of
financial decisions i encourage you to
do the same